how old is a girl too old to be high
value
if she's single it depends yeah if she's
saying is she single um
i think if you've gone over the age of
34
do you know what because obviously
nowadays girls are looking a bit younger
you have to give it to them like oh hey
don't be like don't
don't look younger but you know they'll
say they're asian it's like oh i didn't
even know you was that old
wait hold on i gotta interrupt this we
got a 500 super chat
from michael wood i'm sorry i had to do
that i'm sorry michael thank you so much
that is one of the highest super chats
we've ever got on these shows
that's a good look yeah it's your camera
yo
save that's the same guy from last time
he's contributing
he's coming he wants to see your faces
i appreciate you michael once again i
didn't forget the last one yeah
okay
okay i'm sorry keep going no yeah um
yeah the age thing but don't you think
when you hear the age it kind of changes
though
be real when you hear the age it changes
but it changes on what you how you want
like you know how you view it because
obviously if you want kids if you're a
guy exactly it will change it will
definitely
that's interesting because i would think
it's like 27 28 over
for me
it doesn't mean you're forever alone
with these dads if we are hypothetically
going to do high value women that's a
small percentage it's like if i went up
to guys and said you're not a high value
man i'm not insulting you i'm just
saying you're not in the five top five
percent ten percent of that
i mean
i mean and then if you're a girl and
like you're not in a relationship
or with a high value man by like 25 or
26 like
or you haven't been able to keep a
relationship then i think
there's more that you have to do with
yourself like in terms of revaluation
that's what i would think like 25 26 is
like like because i i would think high
value women get swooped up immediately
because they want they would because
they want family and children
i think it depends on what the woman
prioritizes as well
yeah need to ensure that we're not
getting mixed up between high-value
women and the average woman because yeah
it feels like
in this conversation we're referring to
high-value women but we're also equating
what average women are lacking but the
thing is yeah i think
an average woman an average woman can
turn into a high-value woman depend on
and depend on how she behaves yes it
depends on how she behaves she's
attractive and if she's attracted yes
she can be average like as i said
cristiano ronaldo's woman was getting 10
pound an hour like and she's got she got
lifted right but she was probably still
above average in terms of the attention
she always got from that's probably
that's probably yeah that's probably
true like because she is beautiful yeah
like if you put her in a room like full
of 10 women she's probably in the top 10
in looks yeah that's true and like i
said earlier-ish asking them
if i was a bum but still looked like
something could i still get a high
volume in and everyone's like yes and
she's like
i mean you have to have the femininity
component so it's a feminine bum yeah
like it has to be a a girl that maybe
she wasn't raised with with money but
someone taught her how to be a wife and
that's something that i see a lot of
girls a lot of girls lacking today is
like a lot of women grew up in single
parent homes with mothers that weren't
wives and so they were never taught how
to be a wife what does it take to be a
wife what are like the traits i mean
someone has to pick you
one so a lot of a lot of single mothers
are they were never picked
and two you have to know how to cater to
a man
and make a van feel like a man and i
just think that's something our
generation is lacking that's interesting
that you say
cater is because they were trying to
have you heard the song cater to you by
destiny's child
they were um
it was like either earlier this year or
last year
someone had came out and was like um
this song i
never catered to my man how was he going
blah blah blah but it's like when you
listen to the words
it's it's nothing bad it's just a woman
being a woman her man's coming home from
um
work and she's like let me cater to you
like this is your day let me take your
shoes off let me brush your hair and
it's like why
when people are like we're canceling
that song like no
it makes me wonder like what would you
do for your man after he comes home from
work are you just going to be sitting
there
and
just
not doing anything well i think that
there's a like we have a generation of
women that
think they have an issue with submission
yeah
and i mean my my friend went viral
for just saying she submitted to her
husband joe rogan saw that clip that's
interesting yeah
yeah yeah but it's crazy because all all
i did was like show me your ring what do
you do i love my husband i submit and i
became a better person
you know it's another thing people were
mad at me a couple months back was my
mom taught me that
you should always just say yes to your
husband like whenever he wants to sleep
with you because that's like your duty
as a wife and when i say sex is a duty
as a wife women freak out
and if you're not giving it to him you
can't be mad if you go somewhere else
you really can't you can't
be because you you like he laid the bed
out like you really um stopping a guy
from getting what you really want she's
gonna go find it else um elsewhere
naturally just naturally you do that for
so long it's going to take a toll women
feel entitled to a man's protection and
provisioning but men aren't allowed to
feel entitled to sex
why this is a double-standard lifestyle
that we live in and there's a whole
generation and there's a whole movement
as well on female entitlement that's
just crazy like it doesn't make sense to
the point because it's it's been pushed
out so much and it's becoming normal
like girls are they must they want to
get this off a guy that's a guy that
have a guy but when a guy wants this to
start in the third is oh no you can't
have this ah he's gonna do that
i'm like yo like you females demand so
much but yet a guy can't and when he
does all of a sudden is oh you're you're
you're a lame last [ __ ] or you can get
you can get this for yourself and this
this that the third i'm like how does
that make sense like
for some reason girls think they can
have their cake and eat it too and like
you said as well like there's um there
hasn't been a movement or there hasn't
been
there's been a decline in in submission
and i'm telling you if you're able yet a
guy your guy has a long day or whatever
he's doing and he comes home and you're
out there nurturing him and this is
starting to further i'm telling you he's
going to do you proper not only will he
elevate you're going to elevate with you
that is it this is what i'm trying to
say nowadays people don't uh what's it
called play their role like females
don't play their role and as a result
males don't play the role and if a guy
tries to play the role and the girls
trying to play a different role it's not
compatible i think because i think it's
just the agenda that's being pushed and
i think the agenda that's actually being
pushed is the agenda of confusion
yeah i think a lot of people are
confused a lot of people don't really
know what they want don't really know
what to do which understand the guys are
confused because
obviously they're not making enough
money to be getting the girls do you
understand and and so so that means
they're not getting the girls that means
that there's like there's a lot of
testosterone that's going around and
there's nothing in the mic yeah sorry
about that there's a lot of testosterone
that's going around and it's not being
released what do you understand and
obviously the girls are going around for
the streets right
which in the future kind of damages
their prospects of being wives and stuff
like that so feminism lied to a
generation of women yeah it lied to them
because they said like chase the bag you
don't need a man you can do it all on
your own
and now we have a generation of single
mothers and single childless women and
it's confusion yeah 100 and you know
what as well yeah i don't even mind if
you want to go with our chase to beg and
do what you by all means do that but
know what comes with that kettle of fish
that you want to go chase the bag this
is what comes with chasing a bag this is
how you're going to be
perceived and portrayed but it's like
females want to go out and chase the bag
and do all of this and be quite more
masculine because in a sense that's more
of a masculine role but yet want the
feminine benefit so the feminine
outcomes like
i've seen girls bat out of their league
because they're just freaking feminine
like they might not be the prettiest
girl in the room but they're so feminine
and submissive that like guys are lined
up today
and they just really understand how to
cater to a man
do you think that can equate to
attractiveness in a man like say like
you said they know how to cater to them
submissive and just know how to be a
woman but they're not as
good-looking
ask the guys
yeah i think a guy
will
take a normal seven looking girl oh she
was a five like average average yeah
let's say let's say she's a let's say
she's the highest average 66. yeah
you say she's a high average yeah it'll
take a normal average looking girl over
like a nine if that average girl knows
how to cater i'd be a wife 100. if she
knows how to be a wife and she knows she
knows that the skills is not she's not
going to embarrass my last name she's
not going to embarrass me she's not
going to embarrass my family jenna said
she's not going to be all up in the
limelight and trying to take my shine
and whatnot i'm going to look after her
and whatnot and she holds those values
of being a wife i think he'll take that
over the bad b that's on the street any
day submission loyalty and respect will
give you three points
what thank you